now when you come back to desmos here's
what I'd like you to put in its a
function that we haven't really thought
about before in the context of calculus
let's start with the number two and
instead of multiplying by some kind of
you know X ^ whatever okay I'm actually
wanting to turn this into something with
a power of X so you've got this power
button here the exponent button right so
go ahead and hit that and your cursor
raises up to indicate okay you're going
to write the power next and then you go
ahead and write the X now hmm have a
look at what you got here right
what do we call this with over the last
few days we're looking at what kind of
graph is this it's an exponential
function because it does what
exponential exponential functions do it
starts off real slow they're kind of
skyrockets that's our red one right
zeki a hand up question thought just
yawning that's fun that's all right now
this is what we're thinking about right
did you notice when we look at the
derivative here the derivative I like in
the previous cases where you got some
weed wildly different thing did you
notice the blue function how would you
describe it what kind of shape is it
also an exponential right and it's an X
furniture that's a bit lower do you see
that it's just underneath the graph and
in fact if you want to continue so for
you can zoom in other way and you'll see
no matter how far in you zoom your
derivative if your blue graph is always
just the TV below this graph here okay
always just a little bit so it was even
back out all right now here's that I'd
like you to do come to your original
function up here - to the X right and
this time we're gonna add it it be very
careful with your cursor here in fact if
you noticed if you find it hard to get
your cursor on the right spot or you're
on a touchpad like I am touch straight
you can use the left and right buttons
they'll move your cursor very precisely
here's what I wants to do move your
cursor that's not what I wanted to do I
put that next there there we go
move your cursor so it's right beside
that - there and we're gonna change this
- we're going to change it and subtract
to you it's waiting for you to put a new
base in instead of 2 you put 3 and
for me hmm now you know how there's like
those puzzles we did when we were kids
right of like when we're really really
little and they give you two pictures
and they're very similar
it's like spot the difference spot the
difference right like oh look at that
person's hat is like backwards or so
like that
I want you to have a look right can we
spot any differences maybe to spot some
differences it might help to spot some
similarities what do you notice that's
the same and if you want you can just
change it back and forth in your screen
what was the same from before as so now
what do you think you okay so we're
going straight to a change that's fine
so there's a y-intercept difference here
right that's not the value that it was
previously we'll come to other like what
that is in a minute
do you still notice something else is
different what else do you Oh what what
about what about that gap it is closer
isn't it in fact when we first when I
just first press the novel it just kind
of went almost on top I had to zoom in
to really see that they were slightly
off okay I start another head out what
did you say huh the blue line wait a
second what's the blue light which is
the derivative right where was it before
it was it was just below your ask below
where does Oommen to see it but now it's
just above just above there is what big
screaming obviously which we haven't
said because it's so obvious but you
started with an exponential your
derivative right it's still an
exponential just in a different spot
okay now comes the really fun part
here's what you do go back into your
original function we changed that 2 to a
3 right so just get your cursor in the
right spot we're gonna change it one
more time excuse me but this time
instead of just putting a number in
there like 2 or 3 or 4 or 5 right go
over to your alphabet keyboard like we
have in the past and you can choose any
letter you like I wouldn't choose F make
sure is a a just as a Purdue rule puppy
in the letter a and if you're des versus
like mine it's saying hey do you want
that to be a number of some kind and we
do so go ahead add a slider there now
before you start mucking about with this
slider
can we just have a look at what just
happened all sliders in desmos as far as
I can tell they default to one right so
what are we looking at right now
just before we start mucking about with
it it's constant in fact everything
you're looking at is constant right what
you're looking at is one to the power of
X if X is zero what's 1 to the power of
X 1 to the power of 0 it's just 1 if one
was a number like 2 or 3 or 4 or 5
what's 1 to the power of 2 or 3 or 4 or
5 it's still just 1 right so that's why
this graph is so boring and then you
differentiate it and what do you get
what do you get that's that's that's our
y equals 0 isn't it because the
derivative the rise is there's no rise
at all right so that's why it's 0 here's
all really going to do that we're gonna
muck about with a but before you do it
did you notice when it was to the
gradient function was just below it's
just below right then we changed it to 3
and the gradient function was just above
right I want to play in this interesting
area between 2 & 3 desmos by default
plays u between negative 10 and 10 but
if you go to the UM see this little gear
icon go ahead and tap it little gear
there and you can set a domain
restriction on a it defaults to be
negative 10 all the way up to 10 but I'm
interested in this between 2 & 3 area so
you can change this lower bound to 2
I'm gonna go in there and type in 2 and
then you can change the upper bound to 3
if you successfully do that and then you
can say done now when you play around
with this thing right it's not going all
the way wildly from negative 10 to 10
it's just playing in between 2 & 3 I
want you to fiddle with it and see if
you can notice anything interesting
yeah that's why
[Music]
zoom and it heads it does all right
eyes up for a second people have a look
at what's happening on my screen I'm
cheating a little bit but you can do
this to have you might have noticed
there's a play button over there on the
left hand side so you can just get it to
muck about without you having to slide
it manually okay so you didn't see what
I've got is all and by the way if you
hit play it moves quite quickly at least
I find it does so you can see just here
it's quite small and greyed out so it's
hard to see on my screen but you should
see on yours there's a place speed that
you can change there and I've made half
speed to slow things down and see what's
really happening so what you'll notice
is inevitably because when you've got
two to the X your derivative function
your blue one is beneath and when you
get to three the X if you snap your
fingers it would be above then hopefully
it says the reason that's somewhere in
between and hopefully it's about to
happen right there okay the blue and the
red graphs intersect they sit well
actually they do more than just sex they
sit right on top of each other because
you have an exponential function and
another exponential beneath it what
value did you find was where they
overlap precisely what did you get 2.7
yeah okay all right all right so we've
we've we've nailed it down pretty close
right I'm gonna try at us in fact we can
do better than this
most of you have noticed it's it's close
to 2.7 but it's a bit above right so in
fact if you want see how we're going
between two and three right I'm gonna go
between two point seven and two point
eight hopefully you've realized when you
get between two point seven three point
eight after you
you put it it's it's gone past has it
okay so I've said done and now we can be
super ultra precise in here right have a
look
get in as close as you feel like you
need to you're pretty happy okay this
isn't bad as far as I'm willing to make
desmos go with my finger anyway because
I don't have a mouse